good evening members please be seated
right good evening uh members and
officers of the council and members of
the president public i welcome you to
this meeting of the council
fire evacuation procedures if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
building via the emergency exits
now filming of the meeting i would
advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured i urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
there aren't generally children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
i don't see anybody indicating
that's all right council auburn calm
down
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst this meet is in
progress
i do have to go through all of these
every meeting because though you've all
heard it before it nevertheless is
important for safety reasons
now then
i shall move on to apologies for absence
i have had apologies received from
councillors hart potts and paul moore
are there any other apologies this
evening
yes councillor curry
uh apologies from
any other apologies i don't see anyone
agenda item two minutes of the previous
meetings
as but unusual this time i call upon
councillor everett who would like to
propose an amendment to the minutes of
the last meeting councillor everett
thank you chair i'm just going to move
the amendment and rather than elaborate
on it because i think it's quite
self-evident what i'm saying
um in respect to the penultimate
paragraph of item 7a delete the words
all the and insert but fanuc district
council is the responsible body so
district
and the point is that i was asking for
district councillors to be involved not
town councils
thank you
fine do you have a secretary for that
councillor album i'm sure it's not
controversial is that agreed
it's agreed thank you very much
indeed agenda item three announcements
now
we've it is regret that i have to
announce that former councillors paul
brownlee
has recently passed away
mr brownlee was an independent
councillor from 1987 to 1995
for north dam parkward
in addition it is with regret that i
must also announce that former
councillor mary dwyer king has also
recently passed away mrs dwyer king was
a councillor for central harbour ward
from 2011 to 2015.
it's unusual to lose two councillors so
it's so close together
i'm sure council will join me in
expressing sympathy to their families
could all members please stand for a
minute silence as a mark respect for the
late mr brownlee and mrs dwyer king
thank you very much members
now i'm sure there are members here who
did know these councillors does any
member wish to have a few words say a
few words
yeah counselor everett
yes thank you chair and can i first of
all thank all members and officers for
the many responses to the email that i
sent round about mary
i know that her husband barry and her
children liam and danielle will be
appreciative of them
mary was someone that i met in the
run-up to the 2011 elections
and one thing that struck me about from
the beginning was her determination
she might have only been a councillor
for one term but she was unlucky not to
make it back here three times
losing by 17 votes in eastcliff in 2015
44 votes in northwood in 2019 and just
five in newington last year
she'd been selected for that last
by-election more than a year before it
could take place and sadly by the time
it was held she knew that she was
terminally ill but she was determined to
carry on as long as she could and that
summed up her attitude to the cancer
that unfortunately killed her
she was brave and she remained cheerful
which is very much the mary that we knew
over the last decade
with councillor huxley mary represented
central harbour alongside the late peter
campbell
who memorably put out a ward newsletter
in 2011 announcing his two new
assistants
being peter of course he got away with
that but neither of them were
particularly impressed
she was very proud to be deputy mayor of
ramsgate i think from 2013 to 2015
and as a member of ramsgate town council
and i mean it was a compliment when i
say that she was very much one of the
people and always very comfortable
meeting them
although she lived in margaret when she
first came to thanet she soon stole the
light and moved to ramsgate
she was a council tenant and despite
long-standing health issues she had a
succession of jobs including in a taxi
office in a betting shop and in local
supermarkets
now we all bring different experience to
the council but i suspect that we don't
have enough councillors who live their
life life at the sharp end financially
particularly given the levels of
deprivation in parts of our community
mary was an authentic voice for those
people because she encountered the
issues they faced every day and she
overcame them
she was a reliable member of the labor
group and she was someone who faced her
challenges in life with positivity and
good humor so i know that we in the
local labour party will miss her and
that you will all join me in sending
condolences to barry and her children
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett councillor tomlinson
uh thank you chair
um i would like to uh as i did
on counter everett's um page regarding
mary
i do recall mary on this council
i didn't know her that well and i think
councillor everett here tonight has said
all that should be said about mary and
our regards from the conservative group
to her family
um if i may chair
councillor paul brownlee
was a very close friend with his wife
vivian
in fact i went to his funeral with my
wife on tuesday
to pay respects uh paul
anybody who knew him
i i mean i wasn't a counselor in those
days but you you i think most people
know i follow the mayor the towns and so
forth
uh a lovely character
fun
um i know we're going out live but just
a very short story of a evening i
arranged in 2010 in the town hall
for a drink for past mayors
we left at about four o'clock in the
morning and how he got down the stairs
on the banisters is another story
um
because there's a big ball at the bottom
um
but a lovely man he's going to be lost i
had a lovely talk with his wife
on tuesday
so um
that's all i can say just lovely
memories thank you chair
thank you very much indeed for the
amusing anecdote there counselor more
did you wish
well
rick has already said most of it but he
missed out the fact that she was a very
good photographer
and nobody knew this i've seen her
photographs and she was always good for
her laugh
and she was very sociable person and
very kind
thank you
thank you council scoby
thank you um
yes i i met mary back in
the
the mid
uh
2005 something like that
when she lived in cliftonville and she
joined the labour party and came along
to our meetings
and
um
she was quite a rough diamond but a
heart of gold and i was really quite sad
when she uh uh moved to to ramsgate and
then became a ramsgate counsellor but
cliftonville's loss was ramsgate's game
i also uh
worked with paul brownlee for for many
years at leyland gap school
he was on the care staff at first and
later
moved over to
site management
he and his family were
were lovely and always very very
supportive of the school and the
occasion i remember
well was when paul became a
mayor of
margate
i had to drive the minibus with
loads of children down to the winter
gardens to see him uh being invested is
that the correct phrase
yep that'll do
and
what a charming bloke um
he and his wife looked after a severely
um
uh disabled son for many years and uh
i i've only just heard about his death
tonight but i will be in contact with
viv
uh in just shortlist time thank you
thank you councillor scoby casper piper
thank you very much chair um
as someone who didn't know i didn't know
paul
and mary i didn't know that well i did
meet her a few times as i recorded for
councillor everett in my response to his
email and i would have to say that
despite the fact that she was clearly
very ill on the election campaign train
trail she was very very enthusiastic and
my words to him were i found her both
charming and very pleasant she was a a
lovely woman um
although we were combatants if you like
at the polling offices and so on she was
such a
a lovely woman with great enthusiasm so
although we had different political
ideologies i found her a very nice
person to get to know just a little bit
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
piper well the loss of two characters
will count counselors and we'll miss
them thank you very much indeed members
agenda item four declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest this evening
i don't see any indicated
agenda item five petitions no new
petitions have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule
12
agenda item 5a report back to council
the fanet lifts petition
now this is for information only would
members please note the cabinet response
to the petitions as detailed in the
report
yeah i do have councillor alban you'd
like to come in
yes thank you chair
um
whilst i i
understand what you're saying it's just
for
reports um
i just would like to clarify a point
um in relation to
the last council meeting
uh regarding the budget and the
amendment made that i made at that
council meeting
in relation to the lifts
towards the end of the debate on that
chair
um
the leader
stood up and made reference to
her meeting two councillors in relation
to
uh possibly ramsgate town council being
able to
take over the lift
if i can just put that into context
chair because i think it's important
uh the context of it was that
a
um
it was at ramsgate's 200th and
anniversary
with a lot of
dignitaries etc and we're all standing
there waiting for parade et cetera et
cetera and
uh
councillor ashby came to me
asked if she could have a quick word
which obviously as i know well she did
we did and
she asked me
if she got some money towards the lift
would ramsgate townsville town album i
think we're going into a level of detail
here that's not directly relevant to um
discussing lifts themselves generally
this is in relation to
this is in relation to
a petition
in relation that's right
i just wanted to make it clear if you
could just finish quickly
because it's not all i want
is that
it was a it was a purely a passing
comment
not to do with ramsgate town council and
what i wanted to say chair as well
is that i am inviting
the the leader of the council to come
along to ramsgate town council or to
make go through a formal process in
relation to
the lift transferring surrounding town
council if it's all possible all right
okay well look thank you very much
indeed for that and i'm sure the leader
has noted that um i'm sure the leader
would have been open at any time for you
contacting her
yeah leader would you like to come in
there
thank you chair
yes thank thank you council auburn um i
didn't want to make reference at the
time to the councillor because it was an
informal discussion i'm absolutely
delighted that um
that it can it may be considered at
ramsgate town council i'm more than
welcome to willing willing to come along
to your
invitation
and i'm sure we can have a sensible
discussion and
move things forward to a positive
outcome thank you
thank you very much indeed leader for
that and i'm sure to be very welcome
agenda item six questions from the press
and public two questions have been
received members of the public in
accordance with council procedure rule
13
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
could the questionnaire please come
state the name the cabinet member to
whom the question is to be put and read
out the exact wording of the question
they are submitting to the council
therefore agenda item 6a question number
one from a member of the public
regarding the old town hall and mayor's
parlor now unfortunately the questioner
is unable to attend this meeting so in
accordance with the council procedure
rule 13.6 the question will be responded
to in writing
taking us straight into agenda item 6b a
question number two from a member of the
public regarding catering in westcott
westbrook bay i'm pleased to welcome
miss urath to the meeting could you
please make your way forward forward mr
yours
good evening
the cafe in the west brook bay loggia
building ceased trading about two years
ago
leaving the popular family beach without
a catering service even in the busy
summer of 2020 so last summer we
celebrated when a small converted horse
box arrived offering limited food drinks
and beach goods
however our joy turned to horror when a
noisy generator was used to power the
horse box
this meant that those of us in the
adjacent beach huts could not enjoy our
quiet much-needed relaxing time
with the council please tell us what
plans have been made to provide the
essential catering in westbrook bay from
the beginning of the season in april and
this summer will the council allow the
catering facility to use the mains in
the building which are very accessible i
hear so that the enjoyment of those
utilizing our beautiful and tranquil
beach is not destroyed by a noisy
generator for yet another season
thank you very much miss yours i call
upon councillor pugh to respond
thank you chair and uh thank you for
your question
uh the food and beverage concession from
last season was a temporary license
which has since ended and we are in the
process of looking at coastal licenses
and this area of the prom will form part
of the larger exercise
where a generator is absolutely
necessary alternative all electric or
hybrid power generators should be
considered in line with our corporate
statement for environment and
unfortunately access to the logia
building for power supply is not
permitted uh for health and safety
reasons and i think it's important uh to
add mr sheriff that we're currently
evaluating and looking at the future of
uh the westbrook logo building and we
hope to be able to uh present our
findings very soon so hopefully we can
ensure that there are the facilities
there at westbrook beach that all
residents
know and love and can enjoy so thank you
thank you very much councillor pugh
agenda item seven moving on to questions
from members of the council
seven questions in all have been
received from members of the council
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of the questions from
members shall not exceed 30 minutes i
ask members to be succinct as possible
so straight into agenda item 7a question
number one from a member regarding kent
county council's household waste and
recycling centre consultation i paul
called councillor christendom
thank you
i note from the outcome report of kcc's
household waste and recycling centre
consultation carried out during august
and september last year the unlike
labour-led swale council authentic
district council did not respond to the
invitation to contribute to the
consultation
given the shocking rise in fly tipping
back in early 2020 when the waste and
recycling centres were closed because of
the pandemic i would have expected the
council to have publicly shown more
interest in this consultation by
responding can you please advise why tdc
did not respond to the consultation
thank you
thank you council for christendom
councillor bayford turning to for a
response yeah thank you chairman and
thank you council crittenden for your
question
the household waste and recycling centre
consultation in august and september
2021 saw customers views on the future
use of a booking system at the hwrcs
the booking system was introduced in may
2020 as a method of managing the number
of visits to facilitate social
distancing during the pandemic
tdc officers have communicated regularly
with kcc on this subject but that's via
the kent resource partnership which both
tdc and kcci members along with all the
other kent district authorities
communication through this group is
likely to be the reason why only one of
12 district councils in kent responded
to the consultation
it is worth mentioning that the initial
limit on frequency of visits by any one
customer was removed in december 2020
thereby significantly mitigating
concerns around increased flight tipping
risk furthermore since its introduction
in 2020 the booking system has reduced
instances of traffic queuing outside the
hwrc at margate this reduces the risk
for users and offers a benefit to the
council as the centre shares a common
access with the council's waste and
recycling
i'm
deportments
to say i believe at the moment cases are
presently introducing an on the day
booking system so there should be no
delays thank you
thank you for that council bayford
councillor christendon do you have a
follow-up question
as it happens no thank you
ah most unusual
that's the bayford quite pleased about
that are you
opportunity missed quite clearly
gender item 7b
question number two from a member
regarding recycling in cliftonville west
i call upon councillor curry
thank you chair
my question is again to councillor bob
public we did have a brief chat about
this on monday but i won't strafe the
question
and with regard to the big increase in
household waste being generated over the
last couple of years
recycling within our communities has
never been more important than at this
time
in my ward cliftonville west there is a
much higher than average proportion of
hmos and households where recycling
collection is not possible due to a lack
of bin storage areas
large communal waste bins provided for
these households are constantly
overflowing and probably half of the
contents could be recycled
unlike the nearby wards in dane valley
and clifton middle east there is no
designated council recycling area where
residents can easily walk to and dispose
of their glass and plastic bottles
would the cabinet member liaise with the
relevant officers and the ward
councillors to identify a suitable site
in cliftonville west where sealed
recycled containers could be situated
thanks
thank you councillor curry thank you
councillor bayford
yeah thank you chair thank you
councillor curry for your question
a total of 15 static collection sites
are listed for recycling on the
council's website
one of these is at dalby square which is
in within cliftonville westward and
offers recycling of glass jars and
bottles
other sites just outside the walled
include dane crescent road and palm bay
car park the latter of which also offers
paper and cardboard recycling
the neighborhood recycling scheme also
remains available in a large number of
roads in cliftonville west for wizard
residents who wish to opt in and receive
mixed dry recycling and paper and card
curbside collections
residents who are interested in joining
the scheme can do so via the waste and
recycling page on the council's website
for larger residential buildings
containing flats where the neighbourhood
recycling scheme is not available the
council is always prepared to discuss
the introduction of recycling
collections provided there is space for
bin storage
unfortunately flight tipping and
anti-social behaviour led to the harold
road recycling site in cliftonville west
being removed in 2014.
the council is committed to diverting
recyclable waste away from the residual
non-recyclable waste stream but this
must be in a manner that is sustainable
in terms of both staff and resources and
budget but the short answer to your
question is yes i will liaise with
officers and we'll see what we can do
thank you
thank you councillor benefit councillor
curry that sounded encouraging do you
have a follow-up question uh yes thanks
jay um
not so much a question but more
clarification
um myself councillor keane and
councillor scoby we've spoken to
residents
and what we're thinking of is not one of
these open
areas where that can be fly tipped but
more the sealed containers that in from
in dane park there's three steel
containers less likely to be
contaminated or misused and there are a
couple of um sites that we think could
work and would it be possible to arrange
a site visit maybe with
one or two of the officers just to look
at these sites and uh and discuss things
thank you
thank you councillor curry councillor
bayford help with your portfolio there
i'm sure we can arrange that but perhaps
in the short term you could send me an
email listing the sites and we'll take
it on from there but you know hear what
you say
thank you very much agenda item 7c
question number three from a member
regarding a response provided at the
council meeting on the 12th of january
2022. i call it councillor everett
thank you chair uh at the full council
meeting on january 12th i asked the
leader to share her correspondence with
the secretary of state secretary of
state with responsibility for local
government about the council's
governance to avoid the need for me to
use the freedom of information act to
obtain it she refused to do so claiming
the correspondence was personal and
private
this was never a realistic claim and she
was subsequently forced to disclose it
she also insisted that she'd never ask
the secretary of state to rectify the
situation explicitly stating that she'd
never used those words despite them
appearing in the local media from her
own public statement at the time and in
her email to michael gove mp on
september 15th
i'm sure she agrees with me that
political leaders must always tell the
truth
will she therefore now apologize for
misleading the council at the january
meeting
thank you council everett
i call upon the leader who i'm sure is
going to be able to clarify in full
thank you chair and thank you council
everett for your question
i would like to state that at no time
either in the january council meeting or
any other time has it been my intention
to mislead members of this council
i totally agree that political leaders
and i would like to think that should
also include elected members must always
tell the truth
however i would like to comment that i
believe councillor everett you abused
your privilege as shadow group leader
went under the constitution allows you
the
uh and the other opposition group
leaders to comment but only on the
contents of the report
in this case councillor everett you
refused to
you referred to my correspondence with
the secretary of state which had not it
any in any way be mentioned in my report
and you went on to ask me to confirm
certain details of what i had written
knowing that i had no way to check back
on the facts at that time
i would have been well within my rights
to refuse to answer but as a matter of
courtesy i agreed to respond which now
seems to have been a mistake as
councillor you expected me on that night
in january to remember verbatim what i
had written on three separate
communications five months earlier
for clarity the words in question are
rectify versus regulise which even with
my limited knowledge of written english
have similar meanings and perhaps this
could be a matter of semantics
maybe cancer everett you might like to
consider apologizing to the members of
this council and 142 000 residents of
thanet for taking very little action
during your 20 months as leader of this
council and not attempting to put to try
and put right
the governance of this council and the
dysfunctionality of the senior
management team
it seems that you have if you had
channeled the same amount of passion and
effort you have shown in trying to
discredit me
by filing a standards complaint against
me and now bringing this question to
council you might be standing where i am
standing today
thank you thank you thank you very much
indeed leader uh councillor everett back
to you for a supplementary well there's
a great deal of uh untrue things in
there including the words that rectify
the situation was qualified in their
email which isn't
so i don't know what she's talking about
quite honestly chair it's for you to
decide whether what i say is in order or
not in order and you didn't rule it out
of order so i don't think councillor
ashby's intellectually out of order now
she knows that when she wrote to the
secretary of state the secretary of
state replied that the processes were
already in place to deal with these
issues she asked them she asked the
secretary of state for support and
assistance up to and including special
counsel everett i require a
supplementary question there is a
supplementary question
there is a supplementary question she
knows that those procedures were put in
place under the labour administration
and that was done on a cross-party basis
i collaborated counsellor everett a
question please collaborated with the
formula well i've been attacked i think
i've been trying to reply no this is a
supplementary question
counselor what did councillor ashby's
correspondence with the secretary of
state achieve and will she still be
taking advice from sir roger gail mp in
the future about how to conduct this
council's affairs
and that is the question but i have to
say counselor everett and you do know
better um this a supplementary question
opportunity not a statement in order to
try and vindicate what whatever is the
case at stake here but back to you
leader
thank you chair well
what i will say it achieved is that
i actually managed to get the government
to understand that i believe that we had
problems here before we got served a
section 24 notice so um i couldn't have
got it all that wrong
i would like to say and i'm going to
come back on something that isn't
relevant to councillor everett's
response because he didn't come back
which was relevant to my response
so in councillor everett's 150 word
question the word she was used seven
times and her three times
i can confirm that my preferred gender
pronouns are she and her but i feel that
this might have been a little excessive
use
i much prefer the noun leader or
counselor ashby thank you
well
there is the clarification a little
heated but i do hope we can resolve that
move on now
agenda item 7d question number four from
a member regarding housing targets and
the local plan i called upon councillor
smith
thank you chair um this is addressed to
the leader
it is widely acknowledged including by
north and mp sir roger gail who's um
very popular today that our house
building targets are based on inadequate
and incorrect ons data
they do not reflect than its needs
at the same time actual delivery is
failing to offer the very minimum
requirement of 30 percent affordable
housing
yet thanos beautiful towns and villages
are being irrevocably damaged
while sways of irreplaceable
grade 1 agricultural land
are being lost
will the leader consider following the
example of mid-sussex district council
in halting the current local plan review
process and writing to the secretary of
state again to ask him to revise
these false housing targets
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor smith i call upon the leader
thank you councillor smith for your
question
i believe the reference to ons data
refers to the use of the 2014 data
household projections
the government's standard method for
assessing housing needs for local areas
through the local plan process is set
out in government guidance
that guidance is clear
that local council should use the 2014
based household projections
as the basis for that calculation
the guidance says that the 2014 base
household projections are used to ensure
the historic under delivery and
declining in full affordability are
reflected and to be consistent with the
government's objective of significantly
boosting the supply of homes
the standard method also includes an
adjustment to recognize differing
affordability issues in different areas
it is understood that the government is
currently reviewing
the current is currently reviewing the
current standard method for calculating
housing needs
and that this may change in the near
future
if this is the case this can be
addressed during the local plan process
yes i can confirm i will be
communicating with the secretary of
state on the subject of housing matters
and the housing delivery test in
particular and it will hopefully be a
lot stronger than just the letter but i
can give you more news on that at a
later date thank you councillor
thank you very much indeed leader uh i'm
coming back to you councillor smith in
case you've got a supplementary but
because of um a little bit of confusion
earlier what i'd like to
say and remind all councillors the
supplementary needs to be a question and
it needs to be directly related to the
original question council smith have you
got a supplementary
i will wait to hear from the leader you
will wait well okay i hope i didn't put
you off
agenda item
7e a question number five from a member
regarding emergency housing provision
for people with pets i call upon
councillor wing
thank you chair
the charity street pause states that the
bond between a homeless person and their
animal is profound their animal is their
whole world gives them a reason to carry
on and is often the only source of
unconditional love
the health benefits of pet ownership are
immense
both mentally and physically but many
rough sleepers are asked to give up
their dogs to access services and
support
the big issue and dogs trust report that
research from nottingham university has
found that pet ownership among homeless
people is linked to a range of benefits
including alleviating loneliness
isolation depression substance misuse
and criminality
clearly there is well evidenced benefits
to pet dog ownership so will the cabinet
member seek to assure seek to ensure our
homeless with pets most commonly dogs
are offered equal access to both
emergency and permanent housing as soon
as possible thank you
thank you very much any counselor of
course i imagine some pets could be
problematic that's not dogs of course uh
coming to you counselor at bayford
councillor jill bayford
thank you chair thank you councillor
wing for the question um this issue was
discussed
in some length at the last housing
cabinet
advisory group
we fully recognize the value of pets
particularly dogs to people facing
homelessness or other traumas in their
life and seek to support this wherever
possible
our rough sleeping services rise
does have access to a number of
emergency accommodation placements where
it is possible for people to take their
dogs with them
we can also assist clients in finding
other temporary arrangements for their
dogs to enable clients to take up the
emergency accommodation whilst waiting
for a more permanent home
our statutory homelessness services also
have access to some temporary
accommodation where dogs are permitted
clearly in hostile settings of or
accommodation with any shared spaces we
also need to consider the potential
increased costs and risks associated
with allowing any significant number of
dogs onto a project of the same at the
same time
many dogs are well behaved but not all
and these risks have to be managed for
the safety of other residents and staff
it is definitely more difficult for our
services to secure more move on
accommodation for people with dogs as
many landlords but not all will not
permit their pets
there may also be an additional charge
for allowing dogs which clients may not
be able to afford
tenancy agreements for the council's own
permanent housing stock do allow pets
including dogs to be kept with consent
consent would be on the basis that pets
are well cared for and do not pose a
risk or cause a nuisance to other
residents
thank you
thank you councillor bayford
councilwing do you have a supplementary
uh yes please
uh i i'm very concerned at this time of
year because i've been involved with the
number of uh homeless people who
some of whom are still sleeping rough in
their cars with their pets we'll we'll
have you got a question yes will
councillor bayford uh
try and ask uh the rise team to to give
an estimate of the number of people we
presently have in their cars in these
terrible conditions with pets
thank you councilwoman councillor
bayford thank you councillor yes indeed
i i can so you want to know the number
of
cars sleeping rough at the moment i will
make that inquiry for you thank you
thank you
thank you very much councillor bayford
agenda item 7f question number six from
a member regarding the viking bay lift
in broadstairs i call upon councillor
bailly council bailey
out sorry
good evening
um
at the last budget council meeting
it was my mic on
um there was a there was a proposed
amendment to allocate part of the
unexpected new homes bonus money to fund
the repairs of the broad stairs and
ramsgate lifts
in response to that proposed amendment
the leader said that extensive ongoing
conversations had been held with
broadstairs town council in regard to
them taking on the viking may lift
well and i am a broads and saint peter's
town councillor and i sit on most of the
town council committees and i haven't
heard nothing about this and in fact i
now know that there have been no such
formal discussions
also revealed at that meeting was the
estimated cost of repairing the viking
bay lift being in the region of i'm not
sure if it was 113 or 130 000 pounds but
can the leader tell me if she does
donate the 50 000 pound
compensation from southern water where
the remain where the difference is going
to come from if there is no allocation
for it in the tdc budget thank you
thank you councillor bailey i call upon
the leader to respond
thank you chair thank you councillor
bailly for your question um
i did say there had been extensive um
and ongoing conversations but they were
informal i didn't add that word and i
apologize for that
i have
i have spoken
formal or informal
is rather um in this particular can we
calm down that counselor irrelevant um
to actually getting things done i mean
you have to start the club process off
with informal conversation which i have
done with three of the broadstairs town
council councillors which actually sit
on
my cabinet
the additional
ramsgate town councillor that i spoke to
is um was actually councillor binx and
um i met with councillor binks who is on
broadstairs he's the chair of finance
and general purposes ombre says town
council and she's also a kcc councillor
and i met with her not just to discuss
broadstairs lift but a variety of topics
the purpose of the conversation
was to try and find a long-term and
sustainable solution to keeping the lift
open and running on a secure financial
and maintainable basis
my offer to broadstairs town council is
like councillor auburn mentioned earlier
we had an an informal conversation there
was that broad says town council to take
the lift as a broadstairs town council
asset and i would include the 50 000
pounds donation only to be used in
connection with the lift
it is for broadcast town councils
councillors to decide if they wish to
proceed and let me know accordingly
it is not my business to do make that
decision for broadstairs town council
it is totally a decision for that
council to make and if they decide not
to proceed with my offer then i will
reallocate the fifty thousand pounds to
another community course within the
district
thank you
thank you very much indeed leader um
before i turn to you for a supplementary
counselor bailey just to remind
counsellors all again it's a question
not statement is a question a
supplementary question counselor bailey
oh there's there's so much to answer
there um
um
try and encapsulate it
if if the if boston council do not take
on the lift
i mean you haven't actually answered my
question i'm sorry the the question was
if 50 000 pounds is allocated to lift
whether it's under the guise of tgc or
under the guise of broadcast town
council there is still a short fall
of between the 50 000 and 113 000 that's
the report says is needed to repair the
lift counselor bailey please a question
well i would like my question answered
the shortfall going to come from thank
you
leader are you ready to respond yes
chair
the fact of the matter is broadstairs
lift will open at
and
as long as nothing goes wrong with the
lift then it will continue to work under
the
um assets of thanet district council but
and this is the but
if the lift was to go wrong at any time
after that that it was opened
there is no recourse to thank district
council there are no funds to actually
amend it to get it back online
so i am trying to find a solution a
long-term solution for this lift
and
quite frankly you know
if you
if the council are of a mind to take it
on there will be other ways of raising
the additional money you do not need to
spend today any money on the lift to
have it working it actually is run all
through the winter just for maintenance
purposes to make sure that it stays
the mechanics stay working so
although it's difficult for me
what i'm trying to do is to find a
long-term future for broadstairs lift
but
what we can't do as a district council
we do not have the budget to keep fixing
the lift time and time again we need to
to get it to a sustainable position we
need to spend that sort of money on it
it is around 87 90 it depends on which
part of the actual mechanics that you
want to actually the the maintenance
part you want to do i have got the full
reports that have been supplied by the
officers those reports have now been
sent to
um
to councillor [ __ ]
because she was the one that initiated
the conversation so i'm sure that she
will bring it to broadstairstown council
where you can all decide whether you
want to take the lift or not and weigh
up the risks of not taking it versus the
risk with taking it is not my decision
i'm just making an offer to give
broadstairs town council the lift and a
donation to go with it for fifty
thousand pounds so i i hope that
clarifies well thank you
thank you very much and leader um
i missed all of that i'm missing some
amusing uh anecdote
right okay uh let's carry on agenda item
7g
leader did i miss something amusing what
happened
gender item 7g question number 7 from a
member regarding the goods yard in all
saints avenue margate i call upon
councillor farah
thank you chair um regarding the local
plan
the council i believe has been
instructed to conduct another search for
brownfield sites
i believe there's a suitable brownfield
site in my ward at the old goods yard of
all saints avenue
at 3.2 hectares it could accommodate
about 130 units of housing
it's surrounded on two sides by
residential housing
and it's closed to the seafront and the
town centre
now although this was allocated for
commercial development
times have changed and we are now
desperate to find brownfield sites
and save our precious green spaces and
fields
at the same time
i believe we have at least 30 hectares
of commercial development in progress at
what was called the china gateway area
so along with
other commercial units planned at
westwood
why is
all this together not enough for
thanet's commercial needs
that's my first part of my question and
my second part is
um has the council in any way consulted
with the owners of the all saints site
to ask them to consider
what would surely be a popular housing
development instead of commercial
thank you thank you councillor ference i
call upon the leader to respond
feel a bit like a lift tonight chair i'm
up and down up and down up and down
councillor terence can you turn your
microphone off this is the ramsgate one
and this is council parents
councillor farrant can you turn your
microphone off thank you
decision about the allocation sites for
housing or for other purposes are taken
through the local pan process these
decisions have have to be based on
thorough site assessments which look at
the range of planning issues and are
subject to consultation with other
statutory bodies and sustainability
appraisals
as required by the government guidance
this also includes consultation with
landowners wherever possible to ensure
that the site selected are genuinely
available for development
it is also important to ensure there is
a suitable mix of commercial land and
building available buildings available
to support the local economy and this
site is currently protected in the local
plan
it is an in the intention that all these
matters will be addressed through the
local plan process in due course and
that recommendations on a set of
suitable sites will be presented to
members for decision it would not be
appropriate to pre-judge that process
this site actually is quite familiar to
me because i actually went and had a
look at it uh about six months ago it
was divided into into three sections
it is um it is
it has been sold quite recently and
the intention is for it to continue
the owners continues to put units on on
there so
um
i think you'll find that
they wouldn't be open to having the
conversation i don't believe that their
conversation has taken place regarding
residential but
as we know as it's already in the local
plan as commercial development it would
be very unlikely that it will be turned
to residential use thank you
thank you very much leader council of
france do you have a supplementary
question
yes please
my question was
one of my questions was about consulting
with the owners because of all saints
site because
that's
to me
it seems that we are
we have a local plan with thousands and
thousands of houses earmarked council
fans you're making a statement can i
have a question please i'm just getting
there with thousands of houses to be
built on fields and therefore we are no
councillor
no look i'm emphasis i've had to
emphasize this all night you have to
have a question could i have that
question please
my question is as it was originally what
what's happening about
council officers or councillors speaking
to the owners of possible brownfield
sites for housing now that things have
changed i appreciate what
councillor ashby has said and i
understand that but we no counterfarens
this is you're making statement and
you're talking over we have to have a
question because it can only be answered
a question can only be answered not a
response to a statement consulted with
the owners of all saints site if they
haven't why haven't they and also well
that's your question
that's therefore could you please sit
down council deference that was your
question
thank you no there's no second question
there is a supplementary and that is it
could you please sit down thank you very
much um leader i did find that very
confused if you found it confusing
i'd leave it to you with and what you
decide to answer
all i can do is confirm the process
this council puts out a call for sites
we cannot approach every single
landowner in this district to answer if
they would rather sell their land
to uh for residential development as
opposed to commercial that is not the
process the process processes we call
for sites the sites come in
we cannot approach as i say
and to my knowledge no we haven't
approached them i do believe that they
are actually russian owned so
right at this moment it probably
wouldn't actually be a very good idea to
approach them for that particular site
but
in answer to your first question
no
i do not believe that we have approached
the russian owners whether they would
consider having it as a residential site
thank you
thank you very much indeed leader
that includes our questions from the
public and councillors tonight i would
just like to close by adding that the
whole process can be much more useful if
we stick to direct questions and direct
answers
so i look forward to the next meeting in
that respect
agenda item number eight motions on
notice no motions or notices have been
received in accordance with council
procedure rule number three
so i move on to agenda item nine the
leaders report now in light of what has
just happened with the questions i'd
like to emphasize that following the
leaders report group leaders can comment
on and ask questions in relation to the
leaders report not otherwise thank you
leader
could i go and have a quick lie down
before i give my reports chair
i would like to thank members for
unanimously approving the 2022-23 budget
at the full council on the 10th of
february
council saunders had already stated that
we were forecasting a significant budget
gap but cautious approach combined with
an efficient savings plan and additional
government funding meant we were able to
present a balanced budget
by way of an update on burst 45 at the
port of ramsgate the new marine license
application was submitted to the mmo on
friday the 28th of january
the revised application will be informed
by an environmental statement which is
the output of the eia this statement
will also inform the prior approval
planning application which was submitted
to the local planning authority on the
28th of january
the council's contribution to the inter
experience development programme
in partnership with visit kent has
brought 17 new tourism experiences to
the isle of thana
the project aim is to increase visitor
spend improve the sustainability of
tourism and to develop and implement new
products and services to attract
additional visitors
local residents can also benefit from
the information which is available on
the visit phanet website
the ramsgate future town investment plan
was published on the 20th of january
2022
being a tool for organizations to use
for their own funding bids it also
provides justification to potential
investors and importantly includes the
priorities and projects that have been
identified by the local community
the plan outlines the potential
opportunities in supporting ramsgate's
future and i strongly recommend members
if you haven't already done so
so watch the excellent explainer video
as part of the welcome back funding for
high streets we have partnered with
totally locally and encourage business
owners to work together in celebration
of our independent high streets and to
help them recover post kobe 19.
rail have published updates on the fanuc
parkway station and indicated that
construction of the new station is on
schedule with passenger services due to
be introduced in may 2023
margate townhill is holding a community
pop-up exhibition at turner contemporary
this saturday to give an opportunity for
local people to find out more about the
projects that make up the margate town
deal and speak to the project team
local people will be able to help shape
the projects and inform the business
cases with their ideas and feedback
the garden gate project's application to
plant tree saplings in north dam park
has now been approved and is going ahead
we are developing a biodiversity
strategy for the whole district which
will include the protocols for gaining
permission for projects on council land
so community groups can fully understand
and are aware of our expectations
this year great british spring clean is
running from the 25th of march to the
10th of april 22.
once again the council is supporting
the local groups who wish to take part
we have a great deal of appreciation for
the work of all the volunteers who are
getting involved to help keep our
district and its coastline beautiful and
litter-free
on friday the 18th of february we
activate our reactivated our severe
weather emergency protocol
due to storm eunice
as always officers from the rise rough
sleeping outreach team worked hard to
ensure that any known rough sleepers
were proactively offered relief during
the period of adverse
quintin baker the independent monitoring
officer attended the general purpose
committee meeting on the 26th of january
to provide an update on his progress
all members should have received a
summary which is also available on the
website
and to end on a happy note as you know
later this year we will celebrate the
queen's platinum jubilee while enjoying
a four-day bank holiday with an
extensive programme of public events the
traditional maybank holiday weekend has
been moved to thursday the 2nd of june
with an additional bank holiday on
friday the 3rd of june to create a
four-day weekend
we have launched a new system called
event app where organizers can register
any public event that they are planning
councillor george cupp has agreed to
waive the fee for organizing street
parties throughout this special four-day
bank holiday so residents can focus on
bringing their local communities
together
thank you very much indeed
i don't know whether that's the leaders
big moment council of cups big moment
he's going to answer all my questions
right i call upon councillor everett to
comment on or ask questions directly in
relation to the leaders report
thank you chair
i'd like to thank the leader for the
leaders
um report i'd i'll take on board the
point that council ashby made about
pronouns it hadn't occurred to me
certainly wasn't done deliberately and
i'm always willing to learn about
language i'm always interested in
language as you probably know
um think leader that you have to expect
that if you say and do contentious
things then from our point of view then
you're going to be challenged but we've
always um
we've always dealt with each other in a
courteous and constructive way and i'm
sure that will continue it certainly
will from this side i do think it's good
that we were able to vote unanimously
for the budget
it obviously was disappointing to us
that members obviously wouldn't support
our proposals on the lift and more
in-house temporary accommodation for
those who become homeless
you say you want the same thing we'll
judge you on the results not the
rhetoric because neither issue is going
away as we've heard tonight on the
subject to the lifts
this budget was a first for me because
in 11 years as a councillor here in
elsewhere
amazingly it's the first time i've ever
had to vote on a conservative budget
but one thing i can assure the leader
about is that whoever is in the driving
seat there is always a budget gap at the
start of the process
and it's always closed at the end
because it has to be that's the process
budgets are best judged with hindsight
though
given the sharply rising cost of living
and the pressure of pressure on wages at
the moment we will have to see how
robust the assumptions about costs built
into this one turn out to be
during 2022-23
it's not just our residents but our own
lower paid staff who will be feeling the
pinch
so i do wonder if the leader is
confident about those assumptions even a
fortnight later
one other area of cost which worries me
is the continuing saga of birth four and
five
there are many reasons why this issue
remains to be resolved three years into
this council and i'm not blaming the
leader for them
but we have to be mindful that each
month that passes is imposing additional
financial costs on the council and
environmental costs on the community
through the need for brex to import
aggregate by road instead of c more
delays mean more such costs which
ultimately limit our ability to do other
things that our residents want
we don't want those lorries trembling in
and out of ramsgate but any longer than
necessary
and regardless it seems to me that we
will struggle to contain the costs
within the existing budget
i welcome the launch of the ramsgate
town investment plan and the opportunity
for further engagement around the
margate town deal it's in all our
interest that these initiatives are
successful and the key to that is the
involvement of the community to ensure
that they have a sense of ownership and
understanding of what is happening
than it is much more than its three
towns even though we talk a lot about
the towns
but their increased prosperity can only
be good for more rural residents too
than it parkway will benefit those
people and it will make the various
villages a more attractive place to live
too
signaling improvements should mean
shorter overall journey times from the
towns despite the extra stop
i was i've been impressed by the uh
input so far from the independent
monitoring officer quentin baker
i think we'll wait and see what he says
about what the labour administration did
because he's objective and i'm quite
confident
i'm quite confident that'll be
satisfactory
we do seem to have got off relatively
lightly from storm munis last week but i
know there have been multiple issues to
deal with across the district including
in our social housing
so finally i want to thank all the staff
who've been busy catching up on misspin
rounds and clearing up debris around the
close side
thank you very much councillor everett
back to you leader
thank you jen thank you for your
response sir cancer everett um yeah i'm
very concerned about the cost of living
just today
um i learned that the gas price has yet
again risen by 35
on wholesale prices because of the
and i actually was thinking earlier that
um i thought that we might want to just
take stock
council to
i think about the people of the ukraine
that
are living in a very dark hour at the
moment so
i think we should remember that when we
go home to our warm houses tonight
even though or most of us will go home
to a warm house tonight even though
the cost is uh rising very dramatically
i hope and pray that things do get
sorted out out there in a diplomatic
manner i don't think
killing people and
is a way to resolve any issues we need
to be able to try and negotiate a way
out of it but
i think we have slept walked into this
one and it's unfortunate that
we have probably funded um by way of
buying our gas from the russians that
they
we have actually funded their their war
machine so we need to think about that
um burst four five yes i mean six hours
prior to me taking over this council i
did learn of the eight hundred thousand
pound overspend
planned on the budget
um i can't say it was the best uh news
that i would receive before taking over
the council in fact i did think about
getting in my car and driving in the
opposite direction but
no seriously um i hope that everything
goes to plan and we can get this back on
track and deliver it
because i am very concerned about the
costs that we're racking up with lorries
coming in we have this conversation at
our portfolio meetings
and again it's not doing the environment
any good whatsoever
so we need to keep a watching brief on
that but as you know it's on our risk
register so um we are
and finally yes i think the um it will
be interesting the imo's output will be
interesting and i don't think we're
probably going to take any
get any mileage out of blaming who what
or where we just have to you know take
the advice and move on from there so
thank you for your response
thank you very much indeed leader
i call upon council piper to come one
turn or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report
thank you chair thank you very much
leader for your report which does have a
good deal amount of good news in it
even though we are of course in in very
difficult
times
there are times when i'd like to think
that our group of votes make a real
difference in this council but the
budget was one of those occasions when
it didn't make any difference at all all
of us knew the responsibility of what we
had to do and we duly thanked councillor
saunders for all the hard work that he
and the team have done in bringing that
about
uh some clarification please leader the
comments about birth four and five i may
have misunderstood
but i think i read on the planning
application lists this week
that the prior approval planning
application had now been withdrawn
if i got it wrong i'm sorry if i didn't
could we please clarify that
um the ramsgate future town investment
plan uh the welcome back funding and so
on for high street um leader i have had
a request from a ramsgate town
councillor
for the
um overview and scrutiny panel to
consider calling these things in for us
to have a look at
um i haven't replied yet
um but i i wanted to
use this form to let that council know
there is a reason for i was waiting for
the film to be ready available when we
had our meeting it wasn't we weren't
able to to watch it but i'm hoping that
that explainer video will in fact
explain to all the communities the
purpose of the money the means by which
communities can apply for it so at this
point i'm not exactly sure it would be
an overview and scrutiny matter but
we'll we will certainly look at it if it
becomes one
network rail i have indeed published the
updates uh to their station uh we in
this group believe that this the
functioning port and a fully functioning
airport are the things that will make
this area in which we live
truly open for business and we look
forward to the long overdue decision
from
the government about the development
consent order
the
great spring clean is is going to gather
popularity and momentum i'm sure and i
would just like to say on behalf of the
people of northwood we'd like to thank
the groups of very keen and enthusiastic
litter pickers that we have even though
we're not on the shoreline
with regard to the severe weather
emergency protocol the teams here in
sanet do extremely well in very very
difficult circumstances and uh perhaps
uh as a council in this forum again we
could make sure that they are
congratulated and thanks for all the
hard work that they do
quentin baker has hit the ground running
he's met with all sorts of people he was
telling me yesterday and picked up all
kinds of information and it is good to
see how seriously
this is all being taken
we will recover from the difficulties
and begin serving the people perhaps
better than they believe they've been
served
in recent years
the new system uh called event app it
was good to read about that when
published this morning though it was
rather difficult to share it around but
we managed it in the end uh it's
excellent news that streets can go ahead
and register to have parties rather than
sort of massive events which we
discussed at ramsgate town council last
night massive events down at the harbour
or something like that it'd be nice to
keep it far more local in streets and
communities because i also believe it
will have a greater impact and bring
more
joy and excitement to the communities
thank you very much for your report
leader and the opportunity to comment on
it i did want to stray and ask you how
your golf was going but
not in your report so i better not
thank you very much indeed councillor
piper were your golf balls going astray
leader in the wind
have a little story to tell about that
actually
yeah
is that a question
um first question um the
application you're referring to verse 45
yes i noticed that did send a bit of a
shockwave through the system but um if
you look at it the prefix is year 20 is
the old application that that has to
be withdrawn because the new one has
gone in so um yes you weren't the first
to ask me about that cancer piper
yes the the video
the explainer video is excellent and it
saves having to drill down through each
part of the different elements of it all
the whole point of it really is is an
umbrella that sits over the top of all
the activities that are going on and
there are many that are going on within
the ramsgate uh town so and i just i
just think that um
you know compliments should go to the
team that put that together because it's
it's
i don't very often get taken back by um
by websites or web web videos like that
but i thought that was really excellent
piece of work
the dco whichever side of the fence
we're sitting on i think we all know we
need a decision from this government um
and
whichever way it goes we need to
we need to know so we can move on in
whichever direction it is that we're
going to travel it is hamstringing us
with
lots of different areas obviously the
main one being how we move forward with
our with our housing numbers
the refuse system i think compliments
should go and i think councillor baker
was um explaining our group meeting
earlier that he was at some
very exciting waste uh i forget what it
was actually titled now
oh kent resource partnership
where
we appear to be one of the top
top leaders on on our actual performance
and keeping things going over that storm
period and um everyone else apparently
didn't even turn out so uh i thought we
did quite well there so um
conference
i don't i don't like the facts getting
in the way of a good story council
bakers um and i also love a great street
party i think that has got far more
meaning where you get together with all
your neighbors i remember back when we
were in the middle of the covid and
every tuesday was it tuesday or thursday
we went out and and banged the drums and
and
that was an amazing spirit and i think
if we can get that back and keep it
going then it's great it's a shame that
we have to wait for the queen to reach
you know to reach a jubilee before we
all get together with our neighbours um
and as for the golf yes did have a good
week this week i won the medal of medals
so um although it was a bit blurry and
it seemed to help me this week
as opposed to other weeks when i'm not
very good anyway thank you very much
thank you medals for the leader and
accolades for councillor bayford
i call upon councillor ghana
to comment on or ask questions in
relation to the leaders report
thank you yes i also thank the leader
for early sight of a report
and i'd like to comment on a few of the
items she mentions
make a couple of suggestions and ask one
or two questions
strictly related obviously to what she's
mentioned in a report
we too are pleased the budget was passed
and also want to thank chris blundell
david saunders and the team
again for their hard work
though similar to council levitt we do
remain disappointed that the alternative
proposals on emergency housing and the
lifts were not approved we all know that
sadly the need for emergency housing is
likely to increase this year
and in our response to the local plan we
have suggested that we should keep the
possibility of purchasing units to help
address this under review
we're pleased to note the new visitor
initiatives which are complemented by
other local initiatives like landscape
town council's active ramsgate programme
in helping engage new visitors
the investment of much needed new funds
in manhattan and margie is also very
welcome and we look forward to seeing
their positive impacts
we're pleased to hear about the margate
town deal community pop-up at the turn
on saturday
and i would encourage as many people as
possible to attend and participate
we've called repeatedly for openness and
transparency and hope that this will be
the first of many opportunities for
residents to ask questions about the
projects and help shape what ultimately
will impact their community
and we have consistently opposed the
building of yet another railway station
in phanet since its inception
it has necessitated the destruction of
far too many mature trees and its
associated wildlife habitat
is going to result in a dramatic
increase in traffic and the costs have
significantly increased beyond the
realms of value for money
yet here we are
one question on this
does the leader still expect our
contribution to be two million pounds or
has this now been reevaluated down yet
in line with the other funding being
made available
we're pleased that the sapling planting
in north down park has been able to go
go ahead and regret the
miscommunications of places in delta a
crucial stage
we are very lucky to have so many
dedicated community groups in planet who
help to improve our environment
we must take this as an opportunity to
sort out our processes and provide clear
simple instructions for such groups to
help us work with them in a supportive
and mutually respectful manner in future
for the benefit of all
related to this does the leader have an
update on the proposed planting in king
george vi memorial park which i believe
is still to be authorized
another way we increasingly rely on town
and parish councils to support us is in
helping to manage litter and waste and
we welcome the announcement of keep
britain tidy's big screen clean
and can confirm that many of us
and our party members will be out with
our litter pickers during the sprinkling
we also look forward related to this
to the report of the overview and
scrutiny committee's coastal waste
working party which we understand has
collected valuable evidence from parish
and town councils and from the many
voluntary groups whose patient and
persistent work helps keep fanuc
beautiful
and i'd like to take this opportunity
to thank them all for their efforts
we are grateful to the rise team and
others who worked hard to help rough
sleepers during the recent storms
the storms have also caused damage to a
number of trees in the area and i'd also
like to thank our open spaces team who
cleared away much of the debris as
sympathetically as possible
and finally we're also very pleased to
note the independent monitoring officer
has started work and welcome his initial
recommendations
there is much to be done
to improve our governance and it is
vital that all of us as members step up
to the plate and take responsibility for
improving our situation to ensure our
governance compares favorably with those
of other authorities now and for the
future thank you
thank you councillor ghana leader have
you got a response
thank you thank you chair and thank you
councillor ghana for your comments um
we are making every effort
uh and we do regard it as a top priority
to to add to our social housing stock
and we will continue to do so for the
rest of our term which i think is 14
months so
we will um
keep on searching out sites and try and
find arrangements that we can do to
actually deliver some some social
housing stocks
i must confess the two million um
i i can remember standing up at
uh a meeting
probably about three years ago now might
have been two three years ago where i
actually asked that question
so you might have pinched it off of me i
don't know really um
whether i think the kink county
council's contribution they won some
other fund which reduced their
contribution and i think i did ask at
the time
whether we would be proportionately
reduced as well of our 2 million i must
confess that i don't have the answer to
that but i can find out i will inquire
from the financial team and get back to
you on that one because i can't answer
it
i also can't answer the king the
planting in the king jules vi site i
know it's been discussed with the
relevant cabinet uh members um i can ask
them now or i can come i can ask them
and get them to come back to you on that
one as well
when we come back obviously i'd like to
and there's something i sort of noticed
before that
in council when we get um an evening
cabinet when officers respond or when
when councillors or cabinet are asked to
respond i i think that should go to all
of the uh the councils not just the the
ask of the question so
more than happy to share that across uh
to all members
and um
i will leave the the onus part to the
capable chair of ons um he is due to
give a report i think later on on the
agenda so hopefully he can include that
answer in in in there
so um i believe that's all the questions
covered and i thank you for your
comments
thank you very much leader
agenda item 10 report of the chair of
the overview and the scruceney panel i
called upon councillor riven piper to
present the report and you've an
opportunity further
thank you chair
we've had
a couple of meetings recently which have
proved very informative
and recently that included a visit from
kent police to talk to us about
the issues of modern slavery and crime
in the area it was very very interesting
if you get an opportunity to watch
uh the recording uh i i recommend that
you you have a look
we do intend to ask him to come and be
more specific about certain possible
areas of
criminality in modern slavery uh very
soon
the report is here for members to
consider we have
uh our
list of topics that are being presented
by
cabinet members as usual and also
we have um
topics that
i have written to
the leader to ask for her cabinet to
come and present
to us to do with the green agenda the
comments that we we've declared this
emergency we'd like to see how it's
going
we've looked at going paperless we'd
like to see how that's going how that
might have affected our carbon footprint
one of the issues being have we made a
real difference or have we simply moved
the footprint to our own homes because
we're having to print it all off on our
own computers but there are some uh some
very interesting topics coming up
with regard to uh your question
councillor ghana about the
um coastal way scrutiny review uh
paragraph 2.4 of the report
for this evening says that the working
party is in the process of drafting the
report for presentation to us on the
15th of march
um if you are in attendance that evening
you'll hear it firsthand and then it
will go on uh to council from there so
it is making good progress
i commend this report to members and
would encourage members to contact us if
you have subjects that you would like us
to consider or subjects that you would
like cabinet members to bring and talk
to us about thank you chad
thank you very much indeed uh
reverend piper i have to say that's one
of the fullest um reports from a chair
of open view and scrutiny i've ever
heard
do members have any comments
[Laughter]
do members have any comments
of paper yes as a member could i just
comment that i haven't yet learned the
art of brief reporting that my
predecessor
council of bayford had
there we are there we are well look the
members have any comments
no comments here's obviously very full
council piper agenda item 11 members
allowance scheme for 2022
with members please refer to
supplementary agenda number two
i move the recommendations set out in
the report be adopted do i have a
secondar
the leader who will second that thank
you very much indeed
agenda item 13 exclusion oh where have i
gone
over whether they agree with it oh god
yes sorry do do do members agree do
members agree
it's agreed sorry about that
i'm already brought forward down
right uh where are we thrown me
agenda item 12 20 22 23 the council tax
rev resolution
now would members please refer to the
supplementary agenda number one as i've
already said
i would advise that in accordance with
council procedure rule 17.6 i will call
for a recorded vote on the motion or any
amendment and substantive motions
i call upon councillor david saunders
thank you chair uh when you mentioned
the next agenda item i was almost out of
my chair
because we know that we
were waiting for this report
this report enables them district
council to set its
element of the council tax for
2022-23
however that said in reality there is no
room for variation from the proposal
presented in the report
the real business and hard work of the
budget setting process was conducted by
council two weeks ago when members
agreed the budget
next year's budget is predicated on the
five pound increase in council tax that
is presented for approval in this report
and we cannot consider any further
increase without subjecting any such
proposal to a local referendum
in terms of our increase for next year i
draw members attention to table number
six at the end of the report
as stated the five pound increase
is the maximum permitted but even with
this restriction this shows that our
increase is once again one of the lowest
increases of all public bodies as
district councils as we all know and i'm
sure comments will be made have not been
afforded the same flexibility to
consider tax increases as the three
percent increase for for counties or the
10 pound increase for the police
as a billing authority thanuc council
also collects council tax on behalf of
the number of other public authorities
and bodies
now these organizations have set their
council tax requirements for the next
year the council can also resolve the
total council tax billable for thanet
residents across the district for
2022-23
for members reference the preceptors
are kent county council kent fire and
rescue the kent police and crime
commissioner and the parish and town
councils and the total amounts billable
are set out as you will see at table
number five
finally
i can provide an update on the 150 pound
payable to eligible residents to support
them with their rising energy
costs i can confirm that the government
guidance on the scheme was received this
tuesday passed and that tdc councillors
and civica colleagues are working to
at pace as usual because they do a
excellent job as we all know to ensure
that the measures are in place to make
these payments as soon as possible
to complement this thanet council also
has one of the most generous council tax
support schemes in the county and the
and this additional discount will help
protect the most vulnerable in these
uncertain times
members i move the recommendations
thank you council saunders do you have a
second uh
count the leader councillor ashby
uh we will now begin a recorded vote
conducted by the deputy monitoring
officer
thank you chair um councillors if you
just say four against or abstain um
councillor alban
four
councillor ara
or
councillor ashby
four
councillor austin
councillor bailey
for
councillor bainbridge
councillor jill bayford
councillor robert bayford
councillor boyd
councillor braidwood for
councillor coleman cook for
councillor crittenden
councillor curry
councillor bay day
sorry counselor dennis
councillor dexter
councillor duckworth
councillor everett
councillor farrence
councillor fellows councillor ghana
councillor gregory
councillor huxley
councillor keane
councillor cup
counselor lays
councillor pat moore
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
stuart piper
councillor pugh
councillor ratigan
councillor roof
councillor rogers
councillor roseki
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage
councillor scoby
councillor scott
councillor schunk
councillor schrub
councillor smith
excuse me councillor tomlinson
councillor towning
councillor wallin
councillor whitehead
councillor wing
councillor wright
councillor yates
thank you it's carried
you very much indeed members i believe
that was unanimous
agenda item 13 exclusion of public and
press i move that the public and press
be excluded from the meeting for an
agenda item 14 as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph one
of part one of the schedule 12a of the
local government act 1972 as amended
can i have a sector for that please
council bayford
does agree